oh hi chris kohler for wired com and we
are here at microsoft's e3 2009 press
briefing which just ended and Chris
Baker they had a wide variety of
announcements this year did that yeah
I'll say it was a star-studded show we
had Steven Spielberg here we had the two
surviving beetle showing off the new
rock band game and that's what kick the
show off a very in-depth look at rock
band even though that's not a xbox
exclusive we love the game is fantastic
who would ever thought we'd uh and opa's
androids no it does really illustrate
that rock band very very important to
Microsoft even though it's on every
console beatles rock band looks really
really great fantastic animated
sequences showing all of the Beatles
entire career they now it's 10 songs
that are going to be in the game day
tripper I want to hold your hand and get
back and what else octopus's garden they
announced one track that's going to be
exclusively downloadable for xbox that
was all you need is love they we got to
actually see the game in motion and it
seemed to add one new element to the
gameplay which is traditionally involved
one singer/guitarist face Grimes
yeah vocal harmonies are actually coming
to beatles rock band you can have up to
three singers all singing the three
different parts of the Beatles songs all
at once I cannot imagine what that's
actually going to be like with the sort
of people that I hang out with it should
be a total vocal mess but if you get a
couple of really good singers together
it sounds like could be a great time but
beatles rockband not the only thing by a
long shot that Microsoft was talking
about at e3 this year man I mean we're
to start tony hawk ride where you
actually stand on an actual skateboard
shaped controller and use that to play
the game as you can see it looks similar
to a skateboard it's a little bit
shorter but this thing is full of
technology it's got accelerometers it's
got infrared sensors here it knows where
your feet are knows your hands are you
can come in and actually go for grabs
you can you can lean it you can you can
kick it up you can actually put your
foot on the side of it as if you're
pushing along the whole thing responds
like a real skateboard tons and tons of
sequels also right yeah we got the first
look to my knowledge at crack down to a
sleeper hit that that a lot of people
were really hoping to see more of we got
a first look at left 4 dead 2 sequel to
valves surprise hit on that spots last
year we knew it was going to be big on
pc but it it's all a surprising number
of copies on xbox great to see that back
if you loved metal gear solid 4 for the
playstation 3 metal gear solid is back
and it's now apparently multi-platform
because they announced it here at
microsoft's press conference metal gear
solid rising today it is my pleasure to
announce that I'm bringing the merriest
sorry its franchise to xbox 360 going
star everybody's favorite metal jawed
blonde-haired bishounen right end should
be that that should be really
interesting although again with a lot of
these new game announcements they only
showed a little bit of gameplay footage
what they showed a lot of was Alan Wake
yeah we got to see a look at this
psychological horror thriller game which
is being positioned as sort of like
a serial TV show in the manner of a
fringe or loss or heroes and look very
atmospheric very much game about
lighting and ambience and atmosphere and
it just seemed to really nail that but
all that really ended up being prelude
to Microsoft's big big announcement
which did leak before e3 happened but I
they had plenty of demos to show off for
what is being called project natal two
months ago Don shared with me the natal
experience and the gamer in me would
went out of my mind when I got to really
be interactive with this and I think
what Microsoft is doing is not about
reinventing the wheel it's about no
wheel at all and that is their 3d full
body motion facial recognition camera
controller the idea is get rid of the
video game controller forget about
motion controls how about no controls
and it's just you and your body
controlling the game this is recognizes
not just that there's something moving
in front of the camera it recognizes you
and it would distinguish me from Kohler
it would say this is my face in his face
and hear his arms there's there's a very
high level of detail here also seems to
have a microphone capable of voice
recognition technology that's where
we're going to paint our background
light blue I'm going to slop around some
paint with my bucket throw here and
since i'm making a four-legged animal i
need some help so Abby would you like to
come back up and help me make my
elephant okay so here we go all right so
there's a relevant
I can also choose between different menu
options by moving my hand left or right
if it works as well as they say it well
and again we haven't gotten hands-on
with this we really want to try it for
ourselves but this could be this really
could be a game-changer for Microsoft
and they finished off the show with a
really interesting demo from Peter
Molyneux a Lionhead Studios guys made
fable about well make her why don't you
explain to us about Milo yeah so a year
ago before e3 I asked Peter Molyneux who
was finishing up fable 2 at the time
what he had in the worst and he got a
twinkle in his eye he said I can't
really tell you but it's going to be on
the cover of Wired it's a significant
technological achievement we got to see
it and it was actually pretty impressive
it was a chance to interact with a
virtual person I am I like how you doing
haha you okay actually I'm a bit nervous
you can interact with him verbally and
physically we got to see actually
drawing a picture and then literally
handing it to the person inside of the
game yeah the the camera will recognize
what you've drawn on the piece of paper
and then my load the character on screen
will react to it and say oh you drew me
an orange fish Wow again you know
obviously very controlled demo which the
video we were watching and like
everything else we saw today really want
to get our hands on it and try it out
but I would say overall very interesting
show for Microsoft they're going in a
really interesting direction with his
camera unfortunately they didn't
actually now it's when we're going to be
able to play it so I'm guessing it's not
anytime soon they did very clearly
though position it as as something
that's going to allow them to relaunch
the xbox 360 there was no word of the
what their next console would be even
though we're at the point in the cycle
where you know we might expect to hear
that maybe because of the financial
situation no word of a new console but
Don Mattrick made it made it very clear
that this was something that would work
with every xbox 360 and would open it up
to a whole new audience so the message
was sort of you know we don't have a new
console this new form of interface
reinvents our existing console